imagine it comes out of nowhere a
blinding flash fanning the entire globe
it lasts only a few seconds but when
it's over everyone's memories have been
erased we're talking almost eight
billion people suddenly forgetting who
they are
overwhelmed by panic and confusion
what would the aftermath of the flash be
like and could this actually happen this
is this how no that's not right it's why
did nope
it's on the tip of my tongue ah this is
what if and here's what would happen if
a flash wiped out everyone's memory so
the event will refer to as the flash
happens all over the world and the
result is a massive case of amnesia for
the entire human race losing your memory
doesn't necessarily mean you forget how
to function you can still understand how
to stay alive that you need to eat and
to avoid danger other than that it's a
fresh start for everyone on the planet
what would happen after the flash in a
word hysteria anything could happen
this event would essentially press the
reset button on humanity - all those
years of evolution instead of trying to
wrap our heads around the concept of
fire we might be holding our smart
phones to the skies and shaking them
madly you would know who your friends or
family were or in an even more awkward
situation who you are making out with
before the flash and those are the less
devastating consequences at any given
moment in time there are anywhere from
8,000 to 20,000 airplanes in the air
it's bad news for everyone on board
not to mention anyone below when the
pilot forgets how to work this strange
flying contraption on land things won't
be much better we have millions of cars
in the road at any given time plus buses
transport trucks limos and motorcycles
if you thought there were bad drivers
before brace yourself
money and social structure would become
a thing of the past we might be able to
acknowledge that someone is dressed a
little better than we are but we'd have
no context to explain why criminals like
murderers and violent offenders could be
released with no memories of their
crimes let's hope the desire to commit
evil deeds was wiped out along with
their memories and health-wise we'd be
in bad shape as our doctors nurses and
other medical professionals would forget
their training and all those years of
experience in summary it would be a
really really bad day we would have to
rebuild our society piecing together
bits and pieces from our former lives
after the dust settled would this fresh
start be a good thing things like
political tension would be erased and
some countries may not have borders
anymore or could it go the other way
with the world becoming a lawless
wasteland so could it actually happen to
figure this out let's look at how your
memory actually works your memories are
formed when proteins stimulate your
brain cells to grow and form new
connections you're literally rewiring
your mind however the longer you keep a
memory around the more unstable it
becomes
if you've noticed your memory of
something changing over time or people
saying your story is different it's
probably due to a process called
reconsolidation every time you recall a
memory your brain gets rewired again
it's sort of like an old video tape even
if you loved the movie the more you play
it the more wear and tear it receives
now there have been cases of those
metaphorical tapes being wiped clean by
various different causes and types of
amnesia while something this massive
isn't likely to occur memory loss is a
documented medical phenomenon ranging
from losing a few hours to more extreme
cases like forgetting 20 years but could
something besides an accident or illness
wipe our memories well there have been
studies of what can happen to memories
when a chemical called norepinephrine is
blocked by the brain norepinephrine is
responsible for your fight-or-flight
reflex by blocking norepinephrine
researchers believe they can stop
memories from being connected to
negative emotions in 2015 a research
team based in the Netherlands used a
drug called propranolol to block
norepinephrine in a group of people
suffering from arachnophobia over the
span of three months the participants
given propranolol had their negative
memories of spiders reduced enough that
they could actually hold on to a
tarantula their negative emotions and
fear had basically been erased a common
side effect of propranolol is short-term
memory loss but could a higher
controlled dose actually wipe memories
only time will tell
let's hope something like this doesn't
happen but if it did could we prepare
for it could we somehow develop a
technology to store our memories
what if we could upload our brains for
future use
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]